Vice has this story Canada is taking a
step toward making Universal basic
income a reality the Senate's National
finance committee will study a bill on
October
17th or already did study it I suppose
this about a week ago which uh would
create a national framework for but not
actually Implement Ubi according to a
press release from the office of on uh
Ontario Senator Kim Pate an identical
Bill exists in the House of Commons and
sponsored by a member of parliament
named Leah gazan the bill in the Senate
which received a first and reading 2021
and last April respectively would
require provincial ministers and
Indigenous governing bodies across the
country to convene and determine how a
Ubbi plan could work so they're moving
closer to uh Ubi Universal basic income
they're not there yet here's the sponsor
of the bill uh talking about it it is my
privilege honor and responsibility to be
the sponsor of bill s233 which we've
just uh commenced study of in the Senate
standing committee on finance the com
the bill would introduce uh a framework
to develop a guaranteed livable basic
income right now is the fact that we are
struggling throughout this country with
homelessness food insecurity poverty
Health mental health issues and this is
one way that we could start to look at
these issues it's not the only way but
it's certainly a key way okay so as this
uh Works through the bureaucracy of
course there it's not just going to pass
it they have to first get together and
agree to have a hearing and then in the
hearing they agree to form a proposal
and then the proposal there's another
hearing and then there's so there it's
working through the bureaucracy uh I
think ultimately it'll pass and there
will be a un so-called Universal basic
income um which is just a it's just a
more extensive welfare plan and that
will happen in Canada now and and of
course there are many people that are
pushing for a similar thing in the
United States many many individual
states that have been looking at plans
like this and it's it feels inevitable
in this country as well as we know
Canada is uh they a couple of trained
cars ahead of us on the crazy train
we're on the same track we're even on
the same train there are just a few
train cars up but we're all linked and
uh and so if once we see them uh go over
the cliff we know that we're not far
behind
unfortunately
um and so it's worth pointing out that
Universal basic basic income is a
horrible
idea uh or at least maybe I should
there's a cavey out there I should
qualify it it's a horrible idea if you
care about having a flourishing and
healthy Society if you care about that
if that is your objective then this
would be the worst way to try to attain
that objective on the other hand if you
want Society to Decay and collapse under
its own weight then it's quite brilliant
I mean it's a it's a great way to help
bring that about and we know that the
Advocates of Ubi that's exactly what
they want they want the collapse and
decay of society at least the people on
top who are pushing it right the people
at the topest at at the at the top
levels at the highest levels that are
pushing it that's what they want now The
Advocates just like the the people in
the peanut gallery who are saying yeah
we need a universal basic income for
them it's much simpler they just want
free money and they don't it's not that
they most of them uh directly explicitly
want Society to fall apart but they
don't really care if it does or not they
just want the free money
the problem with this plan well the
problems should be pretty obvious and I
think the biggest issue is that of
course as it is designed it makes it a
lot easier for people to not work and it
encourages people to not work and then
and thus puts a greater burden on those
who are willing to work while increasing
the rewards for not working so we're
taking we're taking the kind of behavior
that again if you want a thriving and
successful Society the kind of behavior
that you want which is people that are
work and work and that they're
productive and you are punishing that
while you are rewarding the kind of
behavior that you shouldn't want last
month the G20 announced a plan to impose
digital currencies and digital IDs on
their respective populations Central
Bank digital currencies allow the
government to track every purchase you
make they could even give officials the
ability to prohibit you from purchasing
certain items or freeze your account
altogether there's reason to be
concerned about this if you have yet you
need to call Birch gold today and talk
to an expert about preserving your
savings in a tax sheltered retirement
account if you have an IRA of 401k from
a previous employer that's just
Gathering dust well you can call Birch
gold and they will help you convert it
into an IRA in Gold you're not going to
pay a penny out of pocket they will
simply convert that 401k into physical
gold which unlike digital currency can't
be tampered with text Walsh to 9898 9898
and Birch gold will send you a free info
kit on gold if digital currency becomes
a reality you'll be glad you have
something pH physical to fall back on
text Walsh to 98
9898 and claim your free info kit on
gold today incentivizing unproductive
behavior and punishing productive
Behavior which again is simply the
opposite of what you would do if you
actually want your Society to
thrive which these people
don't because look what what is the
basic income I mean the number like what
is the number I'm not sure if if they've
settled on an exact number in Canada but
I saw uh I think I saw 177,000 bucks
being tossed around and it's usually
around that you know something in that
range most of the people that are
advocating for Ubi say 17 20,000 25,000
30,000 I've heard that
number what will end I mean let's just
say it ends up at I don't know let's say
it ends up at
20,000 you know there's another way to
earn an income of
$20,000 and that that is you can work
and uh and and here's the thing you can
work almost anywhere full-time and
you'll make at least that much okay it
it is it is very easy so when when we
hear that you know everyone should have
a basic income everyone should be
earning every household should at least
have a basic income every household
should should at least have an income of
$20,000 I mean at a minimum at
least and I agree with that absolutely
I that that is you know to call that a
that's that's below what I would even
consider basic like you we you shouldn't
even said certainly shouldn't settle for
that but but the good news is it's it's
very easy to attain that very
easy okay I was making around that when
I was like 16 years old and not because
I was some brilliant super competent
16-year-old not not at all it's just
that is not a difficult income level to
achieve all you have to do is I mean
literally just if you're willing to work
you'll make at least that much um and
when I say willing to work like you get
a job I mean really almost any job you
work full-time uh you come to work every
you know on time every time that you're
on the schedule maybe you pick up a few
extra hours here and there uh you
probably don't even need to do that much
you come to work you're you're
presentable you have a relatively
positive attitude it's like basic bare
minimum you do the bare minimum and
you'll make that kind of income and and
pretty soon you'll make more than that
it's actually because it's it's
increasingly uh easy to separate
yourself from the
pack um as the bar for the pack gets
lower and lower the easier it is for you
to get over
it so
really you have kind
of it's almost like both sides of this
issue sort of agree on the basic premise
that you know
every household should be making this
basic income 177,000 20,000 at least we
all agree yeah should
absolutely the question is should you uh
attain that income by actually going out
and working and contributing in some way
to
society uh
or should you be able to sit at
home and and sit at home and enlist
other people against their will to work
on your behalf because that's what it
would
mean I think the answer to that question
is pretty obvious if You' like to see
what else I have to say you can access
my full show by going to dailywire.com
or by going to the Matt wallow Twitter
page hope to see you there God speed